how do you detect
that type of gases that are on the
planet
from a distance and that's going back to
that
that's what people were skeptical about
when i first started working on
exoplanets
long time ago people didn't believe we
would ever ever ever study an exoplanet
atmosphere of any kind
and now dozens of them are studied
there's a whole field of people hundreds
of people working on exoplanet
atmospheres actually
wow first there was a point where people
didn't even know there was
exoplanets right when was the first
exoplanet detected
the first exoplanet around a sun-like
star anyway was detected in the
mid-1990s
that was a big deal i kind of vaguely
remember that well at the time it was a
big deal but it was also incredibly
controversial
because in exo you know planets
we only had one example of a planetary
system our own solar system
and in our solar system jupiter our big
massive planet
is really far from our star and this
first exoplanet around a sun-like star
was incredibly close to its star it's
star so close that people just couldn't
believe it was the planet actually
so maybe zoom out what the heck is an
exoplanet
an exoplanet is our name like is the
name that we call
a planet orbiting a star other than our
sun right
extra solar i guess is the number you
can call it extrasolar
exoplanet is simpler but i think it's
worth pausing to remember
that each one of those stars out there
in our night sky is the sun
right and you know our sun has planets
mercury venus earth mars etc
and so for a long time people have
wondered do those other stars or other
suns have planets
and they do and it appears that nearly
every star has a planet has the planet
we call exoplanet
and there are thousands of known
exoplanets already so there's already
yeah like there's so many things about
space
that it's hard to put in into one's
brain
because it starts filling it with awe so
yeah if you visualize
the fact that the stars that we see in
the sky
aren't just stars they're like they're
sons
and they very likely as you're saying
would have planets around them there's
all these planets
roaming about in this like dimly lit
darkness with potentially uh
life i mean it's just mind-blowing but
um maybe can you
give a brief like history of
and like of discovering all the
exoplanets so there's no exoplanets in
the 90s
and then there's a lot of exoplanets now
so how did that come about so many
planets
how did it come about well maybe another
way to ask is what is the methodology
that was used to discover them i can say
that
but i'd like to just say something else
first where so in exoplanets
you know the line between what is
considered completely crazy
and what is considered mainstream
research legit is constantly shifting
this is awesome yeah so before when i
started on exoplanets it was still
sketchy
like it wasn't considered a career or a
thing a place where you should be
investing
and right now now today it's
so many people are working in this field
a good i don't know at least a thousand
probably more
i don't know if that sounds like a lot
to you but it's a lot no it's a
legitimate field of inquiry
yeah legitimate field increase and
what's helped us is everything that's
helped
everyone else it's software it's
computers it's hardware
it's like our phones you have a
fantastic detector in there like they
didn't always have that i don't know if
you remember
the so-called olden days we didn't have
digital cameras we had film
you take a film camera you send the film
away and eventually comes back and then
you see your pictures
and they could all be horrible yeah so
yeah i mean digital
it just changed everything data changed
everything yeah and so one thing that
really helped exoplanets were detectors
that were very sensitive because when
we're looking for
this the transiting planets what we're
doing is we're monitoring a star's
brightness as a function of time
it's like click taking a picture of the
stars every few seconds
or minutes and we're measuring the
brightness of a star
like every frame and we're looking for a
drop in brightness that's characteristic
of a planet going in front of the star
and then finishing its so-called transit
and to make that measurement we have to
have precise detectors
and uh the the the detectors that are
making the measurement
can you do it from earth is it uh are
they floating about in space
like what kind of telescope both so on
the ground
people are using telescopes small
telescopes that are almost just like a
glorified telephoto lens
and they're looking at big swaths of the
sky and from the ground
people can find giant planets like the
size of jupiter so it's about
10 to 12 times the size of earth we can
find big planets
because we can reach about one percent
precision
so not sure how much technical you want
to get but well yeah well how many
pixels are we talking about
like what uh you mentioned phones
there's a bunch of uh megapixels i think
so for exoplanets
you want to think about it as like a
pixel or less than a pixel we're not
getting any information
but to be more technical our telescope
you know spreads the light out over many
pixels
but we're not getting information we're
not tiling the planet with pixels
it's just like a point of light or in
most cases we don't even see the planet
itself just the planet's effect on the
star
but another thing that really helped was
computers because
transiting planets are actually quite
rare i mean they don't all go in front
of their star right
and so to find transiting planets we
look at a big part of the sky at once or
we look at
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands or even in some cases millions
of stars at one time
and so you know you're not going to do
this by hand going through a million
stars
counting up the brightness we so we have
computer software and
computer code that does the job for us
and looks for
a you know counts the brightness and
looks for a signal
that could be due to a transiting planet
and you know i just finished a job
called deputy science director for the
mit led nasa mission test
and it was my purview to make sure that
we got the
planet candidates the transiting light
curves out to the community so people
could follow them up
and figure out if they're actual planets
or false positives
so publish the data so that people could
just uh yeah
publish data all the all the data
scientists out there could crunch and
see if they can
exactly something they can discover
something and in fact the nasa policy
for this mission
is that all the data becomes public as
soon as possible
so anyone could act it's not as easy as
it sounds though to download the data
and look for planets
but there is a group called
planethunters.org and they take the data
and they actually crowdsource it out to
people to look for planets yeah and they
often find
find signals that our computers and our
team missed
you